in the newest division two expansion
warlords of New York you'll visit new
locations meet new psychopathic thugs
and be given a new directive to hunt
down rogue division agent Aaron keener
before he can unleash a new bioweapon
only already desperate citizens of New
York if you love the division gameplay
this new iteration of the game expands
the narrative experience and if you've
never played any of the series this is a
great time to jump in warlords of New
York is setting a post-apocalyptic and
virus riddled lower Manhattan hit by a
hurricane that devastated the already
wrecked streets the scene continues to
be incredibly dire despite the
destruction that debris the gunfire and
the garbage you'll still be able to
notice iconic imagery of a classic New
York a constant reminder of where you
are and what used to be there if you're
an agent fresh out of training let me
catch you up on the situation a
weaponized form of smallpox known as
green poison aka the dollar flu was put
on cash and spread through New York City
during the fall of 2015 during one of
the busiest Black Friday sales ever
three different federal agencies
including members of the strategic
homeland division were dispatched to
deal with both the quarantine and the
unrest that happens when you tell people
they can't leave a place with a deadly
virus in it in central Manhattan the
Anarchy had spread so widely that
government peacekeepers were forced to
retreat leaving one first wave division
agent Erin keener alone to defend an
apartment building full of civilians
from Marauder attacks throughout the
ordeal his request for backup were
denied and the apartment was set ablaze
killing everyone inside except the lone
agent
it was then surrounded by a world that
was literally falling apart that a
broken Keener vowed revenge against the
division against the government man
against pretty much any form of
authority trying to rebuild the world
the way it used to be in the first
division title you play as an agent that
has to deal with everything New York
natives throw at you like grenades malt
offs and really painful insults and if
that weren't enough you're also tasked
with the takedown of a rival who's
received every bit of the elite training
that you went through in the end though
Aaron evades capture with samples of the
green poison virus notes on how it was
created and a means of replication in
the division 2 story up to this point
our protagonist has been in Washington
DC helping to rebuild civil
from the madness among the monuments
meanwhile keener has enlisted the
services of other like-minded rogue
agents and helping him to turn lower
Manhattan into his own personal
stronghold complete with evil minions in
a natural moat in warlords of New York
you're headed back to the Big Apple to
crack some henchmen heads and stop
Keener's army from deploying his new
flavor of the green poison keener has
used the 7 months during which the
division was busy in DC to cement his
place in lower Manhattan while granting
each of his cadre of former division
agents zones within the city you'll hunt
for them an iconic boroughs like two
bridges Civic Center Battery Park in the
financial district in order to convince
them through violence to betray Keener's
location you won't just be walking up to
these guys without piling up the bodies
of their indoctrinated sick of antic
butthead followers who are powered by
amazingly adaptable AI by the way look
at this look at your flanking me looking
you'll encounter familiar gangs of
escaped Rikers Island prison inmates and
meet former city sanitation workers who
since learned to love and harness the
power of flamethrowers originally to
burn out disease but more recently to
burn your face off not everyone is out
to stop your crusade though civilian
groups called peacekeepers will lend a
hand in your struggle much like the JTF
groups you may be familiar with from
your previous forays in the Big Apple
after all it's really the colorful
locals that make any trip to New York
memorable every location lower Manhattan
is completely new to the franchise since
the first division took place in midtown
Manhattan not far if you could take the
subway but fighting Street to Street
makes the area feel huge
war lords casts aside the shackles of
the level 30 character cap that
operatives have long been bound to by
increasing the upper limit to 40 and the
progression doesn't stop there
alongside your character's level there's
an infinite leveling system for your
shade level that grants you
progressively cooler perks with
continual progression allowing you to
humblebrag without saying a word
what are those levels without new skills
to play around with right to broaden
gameplay and expand your camp busting
capabilities Ubisoft has introduced four
new skills into your agents repertoire
you'll be throwing out hologram decoy
Shaak minds and two new versions of an
old favorite from the original division
sticky bombs in an effort to combat the
hoarding of weaponry and random
tchotchkes found around in the wild
you've been given a new gear bench
combined with the updated item
comparison view you'll know exactly what
to feed into the gear grinder want to
add a little spice to a favorite mission
directives or gameplay modifiers that
you can select at the beginning of a
mission or open-world activity to
increase the difficulty but also to add
bonus multipliers for your XP one of the
most noticeable changes in the division
two is the seasonal shift from the
frozen depths of a new york winter to
the warm almost inviting sun-drenched
days of summer without the horrific
smell of new york and summer because
it's thankfully a video game the
expansions out now so you can get
knee-deep in new york's worst with new
missions new enemies new locations and a
city bus load of weaponry designed to
help you tear it all down warlords in
new york is playable in both single and
co-op modes but if you find yourself in
need of some backup hit me up and we'll
paint the town red with blood